well have you heard of the term
veganwary that's vegan
and january combined and it's the
world's largest vegan movement inspiring
people
to try going vegan this month and beyond
rocky theaters is live at go vegan cafe
to show us how
a vegan lifestyle is done and how it can
benefit your health
thank you so much christian yes we are
go vegan cafe and this is like a
i can call it a vegan mecca vegan utopia
it's got everything you need
to go vegan and just maybe even just try
it right oh absolutely you can benefit
from maybe just a few days going vegan a
week absolutely
yeah so this is lou this is lou she has
many hats here at go vegan
and i want to talk to you about we were
talking earlier about how
vegas or you can say lost vegan
is actually a pretty vegan a huge vegan
community
oh yeah absolutely we have probably
about 40
100 vegan restaurants as well as at
least 40 or 50 that have a designated
vegan
menu available at omni restaurants
awesome and of course
we're here at a vegan restaurant locally
and i want to talk about your menu
because
honestly i'm extremely full right now
because louis fed my photographer and i
who are not vegan
and a lot of people think you can't get
full off being vegan and i'm here to say
that is not true so let's talk about
what items we have here on the street
sure because we offer a raw menu and a
cooked menu this is what our raw
pizza looks like this is the traditional
and the mexicali
edible art this is our roasted garlic
and veggie pizza with
sausage sausage sausages the air coats
are very important
mexi burger with uh waffle cup potato
fries
take a look at that you would think
that's a real burger and it is
not it's a really good burger though
there's a curry soup
a caesar salad as well as a breakfast
sandwich on a ciabatta roll
i love that we are definitely breaking
down the myth of not of going
hungry vegan because you can actually
fulfill your life
in this lifestyle absolutely absolutely
and helping your health helping the
environment helping the animals
all in one swoop i love it well coming
up later in the show we are going to
talk juicing because that's another
great way
absolutely to live clean all right we'll
send it back to you guys in studio
all right juicing is good stuff thanks
rocky we'll check back with you
momentarily